bien ministre monsieur le Président de
la radar à travers vous monsieur le
Président c'est l'engagement le courage
et la résistance du peuple ukrainien que
nous voulons honorer cet après-midi jour
après jour il force l'admiration du
monde parce qu'il n'y a aucun doute pour
nous oui la Russie a violé la
souveraineté ukrainienne et porte seule
la responsabilité du retour de la guerre
en Europe avec son cortège insensé de
crime contre l'humanité de bout de chat
à carquif la France doit aider l'Ukraine
et notre pays n'a passé d'étendre son
soutien militaire humanitaire et
financier
mais madame la Première ministre le
conflit figé depuis l'automne connaît
des mouvements inquiétants depuis
plusieurs semaines avec la perspective
d'une offensive russe de grande ampleur
qui pourrait aligner jusqu'à un
demi-million de nouveaux conscrits le
président Poutine est habité par les
idées de destruction et de reddition de
l'Ukraine engagée dans une guerre qui
n'a aucun sens politique ou économique
sauf à vouloir reconstituer le glacis
soviétique un film même ténu de
communication avec l'agresseur a été
maintenue depuis le début du conflit
mais les espoirs de retrouver une porte
de sortie négociée à court terme
s'amenuise devant l'intransigeance russe
bien sûr aucune négociation n'est
possible tant que l'Ukraine est sous les
bombes
aujourd'hui la France grande puissance
puissance européenne puissance membre du
de droit du Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU
invocation à imaginer la fin de la
guerre aujourd'hui pourtant elle ne fait
pas entendre sa voix singulière notre
pays donne le sentiment d'être à la
remorque de ses partenaires européens et
de son allié américain parfois en
décalage avec eux en tout cas sans
initiative propre ce n'est pas à la
hauteur de notre histoire sans doute la
position française souffre-t-elle
de l'isolement du président de la
République jusque dans son propre pays
une des seules démocraties dans laquelle
le chef de l'État ne partage pas ses
opinions stratégiques avec le Parlement
vous devez madame la Première ministre
vous appuyez sur le Parlement pour
construire la position française et
notamment partager avec nous un état des
lieux réaliste de nos capacités de
soutien militaires nous dire quels sont
les scénarios de des escalades et de
paix pollukraine qui guide votre
gouvernement madame la Première ministre
la solidarité de la France envers le
peuple ukrainien sera d'autant plus
solide quel sera éclairée et partagée
êtes-vous prêtes à organiser ce débat au
Parlement
[Applaudissements]